hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
für viele von euch da draußen ist die
Pandemie wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen
vorbei oder wie oft tragt ihr noch Maske
das könnt ihr uns ja mal in die
Kommentare schreiben das ist aber
tatsächlich nicht für alle Menschen so
in Deutschland aktuelle Studien gehen
davon aus dass hier in Deutschland
mindestens eine Million Menschen an long
Kur wird also den Folgen einer
kovet-infektion erkrankt sind und heute
ist deswegen der erste offizielle
internationale long-kurve Gedenktag ja
und anlässlich dieses Tages hat sich die
Initiative nicht genesen heute vor dem
Forschungsministerium versammelt sie
haben Bilder von Betroffenen aufgehängt
und protestiert und zwar für die
Entwicklung und Erprobung von
Medikamenten und Behandlungsmethoden für
postwag für longkow wird für Symptome
das fatig Syndroms das sind alles
Krankheitsbilder die nach so einer Kurve
Erkrankung auftreten können ja und
eingeladen waren dazu auch die zwei
Menschen in der Bundesregierung die für
die Erforschung und
Therapiemöglichkeiten von Krankheiten
verantwortlich sind
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach und die Forschungsministerin
Bettina stark Watzinger und ja gekommen
sind die zwei zu diesem Termin nicht wie
ist das eigentlich long Kurve zu haben
wie schränkt es den Alltag ein und was
tut eigentlich die deutsche Regierung
aktuell um den betroffenen Menschen zu
helfen ignoriert sie die am Ende sogar
darüber wollen wir heute sprechen und
zwar mit Ricarda piepenhagen sie ist
Betroffene und Initiatorin der
Initiative nicht vergessen die wir
gerade nicht genesen die wir gerade
gesehen haben wir wollen sprechen mit
der Gesundheitspolitikerin Linda
Heitmann die die Grünen im
Gesundheitsausschuss des Bundestages
vertritt und wir wollen sprechen mit
Professor Carmen scheibenbogen sie
Island Kurve Expertin an der Charité
aber wie immer wenn wir hier heute auch
mit euch sprechen wenn ihr Fragen zum
Thema habt oder Anmerkung für unsere
Expertinnen die wir heute hier haben
dann teilt die gerne mit uns schreibt
uns gerne hier im Chat auf Youtube oder
per Mail an ZDF heute - live at zdf.de
jetzt sprechen wir aber erstmal mit
einer die sich auskennt weil sie selber
betroffen ist und zwar mit Ricarda
piepenhagen sie ist long Kurve betroffen
und Initiatoren der Initiative nicht
gelesen hallo Frau piepmagen schön dass
Sie bei uns sind hallo
viele die uns gerade zuschauen die
können sich das vielleicht gar nicht
vorstellen wie das ist long Kurve zu
haben erzählen Sie uns doch mal wie hat
sich denn ihr Leben ganz konkret durch
dieses Erkrankungsbild verändert
ja ich bin eigentlich noch eine der
Glücklichen Patientinnen und Patienten
die nicht so schwer betroffen ist wie
manche Krankheitsbilder das tatsächlich
abliefern
bei mir äußert sich das in Sehstörungen
und in Konzentrationsstörungen
beziehungsweise in Parkinson ähnlichen
zitteranfällen nach Belastung und ja ich
habe eine endothilitis eine
Gefäßentzündung und die ist auch
deutlich sichtbar also meine Gefäße
treten deutlich hervor
und ja durch diese Entzündung die ja
ständig stattfindet die Multi
systemische habe ich halt ähm große
Probleme mit Schwindel mit
tachyokardinen das heißt mein Pulsschlag
ist erhöht so dass ich wenn ich vom
Stuhl aufstehe ähm ein Puls von 180 zu
110 habe währenddessen ich im Sitzen
noch ein Puls von
100 zu 60 hatte und ähm ja meine
Regulationsmechanismen im Körper nicht
richtig funktionieren aufgrund dieser
Gefäßentzündung Engstellung Weitstellung
autoimmunologischen Prozessen ja und ja
so kann man halt nicht gut zur Arbeit
gehen
ja also wirklich ein Krankheitsbild was
den Alltag total beeinflusst und das
ganze Leben verändert und mit ihrer
Initiative machen sie ja darauf
aufmerksam wie die Lebensrealität von
Menschen sich verändert unter anderem
auf dem instagram-kanal und auf den
wollen wir jetzt mal einen Blick werfen
ich zeige euch das mal
wir werfen mal einen Blick hier auf den
insta Account von nicht genesen und da
seht ihr hier sind ganz viele Menschen
deren Schicksal hier geteilt wird z.B
Laura 29 Jahre aus Berlin Modedesignerin
und Model arbeitsunfähig seid April
2022 oder hier haben wir Marion 51 Jahre
aus Nordrhein-Westfalen internationale
sales Key Account Managerin auch
arbeitsunfähig seit Mai 2021 musst du
einmal überlegen das ist jetzt fast zwei
Jahre lang schon so und was auch
auffällt ist das hier total viele Frauen
auf den Bildern sind das ist eine Gruppe
die besonders von longo wird betroffen
ist Frau piepenhagen
was sind das denn für Menschen die sie
da kennenlernen kann man irgendwie sagen
ist das eine bestimmte Altersgruppe
verbindet die irgendwas und was sind die
größten Beschwerden die sie von denen
mitkriegen
also wir haben tatsächlich bundesweit
Menschen abgebildet die irgendwie das
Krankheitsbild longkowitz-syndrom
erfüllen die schwersten Fälle von ihnen
entwickeln tatsächlich die schwere
neuro-immunologische Erkrankung mecfs
myalgische enzephalomyelitis oder
chronisches fatix-syndrom schon bekannt
seit 1969 und in der WHO dort so
gelistet ähm
300.000 Menschen und darunter 40.000
Kinder waren schon von dieser Krankheit
im Vorfeld betroffen die man durch jeden
viralen Infekt wie einfach eine
Influenza oder aber auch andere virale
Infekte
und andere Dinge sich zu ziehen kann und
diese Zahlen verdoppeln sich jetzt und
das sieht man ganz deutlich
am Fachkräftemangel haben wir gesagt
weil wir auf dieser Seite wirklich alle
Altersklassen finden alle Geschlechter
tatsächlich auch jungen Mädels viele
junge Leute gerade junge Leute die
wahrscheinlich noch ein gutes und
intaktes Immunsystem hat was dann
wahrscheinlich daraus resultierend
überschießt und wir haben auch viele
Kinder ja und ähm wie gesagt wir haben
die Initiative eröffnet und haben die
ganze Bundesrepublik abgebildet und
festgestellt dass schließlich alle
Berufsgruppen vertreten sind
ja und vor allem was er jetzt auch schon
aufgefallen ist diese also einfach dass
man nicht mehr arbeiten gehen kann das
ist ja ein total krasser Einschnitt im
täglichen Leben der auch das ganze Leben
verändert und deswegen haben sie und
andere Betroffene ja heute demonstriert
vor dem Forschungsministerium wir haben
gerade die Bilder gesehen wir haben Sie
denn diese Demo hatte erlebt
ja in erster Linie sehr anstrengend
natürlich ja weil es ist ja klar ich
musste mich auch vor Ort bewegen
natürlich haben viele Helfer dort
geholfen und ähm den Aufbau initiiert
den habe ich natürlich nicht selbst
vorgenommen trotzdem hatte ich viele
Interviews vor Ort es sind
Bundestagsabgeordnete gekommen die die
Sache genauso sehen wie wir Betroffenen
und ja es war
wahrscheinlich nötig erwärmen ist und
Aufmerksamkeit für die Sache heute am 15
März am internationalen longkonie day
ähm ja zu präsentieren weil es betrifft
ja nicht nur Deutschland sondern es ist
ein weltweites Phänomen
ja wir haben es gerade gehört auch
einige Politiker und Politikerinnen
waren da und wenn wir uns ein bisschen
die politische Dimension dieses Problems
angucken dann fordern Sie und die
Initiative und auch andere Betroffene ja
immer wieder mehr
Grundlagenforschung des
Forschungsministeriums und das hat heute
im Bundestag auch die Opposition
gefordert nämlich die CSU CDU-Fraktion
und in diese Debatte im Bundestag da
gucken wir jetzt mal rein
Müdigkeit Erschöpfung konzentrations-
und Gedächtnisprobleme die Liste an
symptomballonkovit ist lang
beim Lernen es geht halt nicht alles in
den Kopf es dauert lange
und man musste dann für eine
Leistungskontrolle dann vielleicht auch
eine Woche früher anfangen und nicht
erst zwei Tage vorher jemand anderer
weil man das halt alles nicht mehr so
abspeichert im Kopf doch es gibt auch
Betroffene die ihren Alltag überhaupt
nicht mehr meistern können vor allem
diese Menschen warten sehnlichst auf die
Entwicklung und Erprobung von
Medikamenten und Behandlungsmethoden das
Bundesforschungsministerium hat bisher
einen Großteil der beantragten
Fördergelder dazu abgelehnt nur 15 von
73 Projekten zu Erforschung von Corona
Langzeitfolgen wurden unterstützt das
entspricht einer Fördersumme von 12,5
Millionen Euro
zu wenig sagt die Opposition
das wird weder dem Leiden der einer
Million Menschen in Deutschland gerecht
die daran leiden noch der Größe der
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Herausforderung
und meine lieben Kolleginnen und
Kollegen schon gar nicht dem
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden der
dadurch entsteht
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
hatte angekündigt die Forschung zur
Versorgung von Patienten mit lonkovic
mit 100 Millionen Euro fördern zu wollen
mit dem Bundesgesundheitsministerium
werde ich ein Programm auflegen wo wir
also die Folgen von longkow wird und
also das wären dann auch Postfach wäre
dann mit betroffen wo wir die ist also
untersuchen und auch die Versorgung
verbessern wann und ob dieses Geld kommt
wird derzeit verhandelt aber das
bedeutet nicht dass es mehr Forschung
zur Medikamenten geben wird dafür ist
hauptsächlich das bundesforschungs- und
nicht das Gesundheitsministerium
zuständig
ja über diese Forschung und über diese
Forderung wollen wir sprechen und zwar
zum einen mit Frau piepenhagen die kennt
ihr schon von eben als Aktivistin und
Betroffene und mit der grünen
Gesundheitspolitikerin Linda Heitmann
schön dass Sie bei uns sind hallo
ja guten Tag wenn ihr da draußen Fragen
an die beiden habt oder einfach mal eure
Meinung zum Thema loswerden wollt dann
macht das gerne einfach hier im Youtube
Chat oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zedf.de Frau piepenhagen wir
haben jetzt gerade gehört Herr
Lauterbach unser Gesundheitsminister
will 100 Millionen klar machen für die
sogenannte Versorgungsforschung das
klingt ja jetzt erstmal nach einer Menge
Geld oder
ja aber das hilft
ja okay haben wir beide geantwortet Frau
piepmann machen sie mal weiter
ja also
Versorgungsforschung soll ja in erster
Linie erstmal erforschen wie gut oder
wie schlecht die Versorgung ist also
sprich wer ist der erste Ansprechpartner
der Hausarzt oder der fachspezialist ist
eine Reha kontraindiziert oder ist sie
doch tatsächlich bei also es gibt ja
viele Krankheitsbilder bei der die
Aktivierung kontraindiziert ist wir
haben viele Patienten die schon zwei
Rehas hinter sich haben auf zwei Beinen
rein und im Rollstuhl zurück kamen
zumindestens die die das Krankheitsbild
Post exerzelle Malays erfüllen also
sprich wo Aktivierung wirklich zur
zustandsverschlechterung und und
schlechtesten Falle auch zur
zustandsverschlechterung die nicht mehr
reversibel ist hinführt und ja diese
ganze Versorgung und eine neue Seite auf
der Seiten des Bundesministeriums bzw
eine Hotline ist den Menschen die schon
seit dem 4 Jahr jetzt erkrankt sind also
nichts nütze weil sie kennen sich besser
aus über das Krankheitsbild als dass sie
jemals in Informationen in der Hotline
erfahren würden das macht vielleicht für
Neuerkrankte eine tolle Sache sein aber
ja wir wollen einfach raus aus der
Verwaltung und Versorgung rein ins
Arbeitsleben hin zu Therapie und
Medikamenten Studien die nicht nur
Symptome lindern sondern tatsächlich das
Krankheitsbild bewältigen und die
Mehrheit der Masse aus dem Betten holt
und zur Genesung verhältst
Frau Heitmann sie wollten ja gerade
schon das Wort ergreifen und sind ja
auch Teil der Grünen also der dritte
Teil quasi der Ampel Koalition wir
sprechen hier schon viel über die FDP
wir sprechen über die SPD jetzt haben
wir sie quasi als dritten Teil dieser
Ampelkoalition können Sie uns sagen
warum Lauterbach sich denn jetzt für
diese 100 Millionen in der Versorgung
engagiert die ja Frau piepenhagen gerade
als nicht so sinnvoll erachtet
also ich glaube es ist in der Forschung
wirklich wichtig dass man alle Teile
sieht und berücksichtigt und bisher wird
aus dem
Bundesforschungsministerium wird aus
drei verschiedenen Töpfen gefördert die
Forschung an der Krankheit selber die
Forschung auch an Medikamenten und Herr
Lauterbach möchte nun gerne das auch aus
den Geldern seines eigenen Ministeriums
daran geforscht wird wie ist die
Versorgungslandschaft bisher in
Deutschland aufgestellt und welche
Lücken gibt es wo müssen wir diese
schließen und ich halte das tatsächlich
auch für sehr wichtig denn wir sehen
einfach dass die Versorgung bis jetzt
völlig unzureichend ist wir haben als
Politik auch gesetzlich den GBA dazu
verpflichtet bis Ende diesen Jahres bis
Ende 2023 gute Versorgungsstrukturen für
die Betroffenen in Deutschland
aufzubauen und wirklich vorzuhalten
und ob das denn gelingt das können wir
nur dann wissen wenn wir jetzt auch
erforschen ob das passiert und wo die
Lücken sind die hinterher dann auch
geschlossen werden müssen und Herr
Lauterbach ist damit diesen 100
Millionen an den Haushaltsausschuss
herangetreten die er gern in seinem
Haushalt für dieses Vorhaben hätte da
laufen jetzt Verhandlungen und da wird
der Haushaltsausschuss sicher mit Herrn
Lauterbach darüber verhandeln wie viel
Geld am Ende allein für diese
Versorgungsforschung wirklich für
sinnvoll erachtet wird aber ich stimmt
Frau piepenhagen zu die Forschung in die
Krankheit Ursachen selber und auch in
wirksame medikamententherapien sind
natürlich auch wichtig wenn ich
vielleicht sogar noch wichtiger und da
kommen die Gelder wie gesagt aus dem
Forschungsministerium und da werden auch
jetzt schon jedes Jahr Gelder bereit
gestellt und abgerufen aber auch wir
wünschen uns immer dass es noch mehr
sein könnte
ja um diese Forschungsgelder aus dem
Forschungsministerium das muss man
vielleicht noch mal kurz erklären für
die da draußen den das nicht so klar ist
es gibt also einen Topf im
Forschungsministerium der heißt
Grundlagenforschung da kann man Geld da
draußen abrufen und der beschäftigt sich
wie gesagt mit Grundlagen einer
Krankheit mit Medikamentenforschung und
dann gibt es im Gesundheitsministerium
noch eine Eintopf der heißt
Versorgungsforschung das sind die
möglichen 100 Millionen über die wir
gerade gesprochen haben da geht es eher
um die Versorgungssituation in
Deutschland jetzt war ja aber auch Teil
der Debatte heute im Bundestag die Frage
von der CSU von der cdu/csu-fraktion
warum da bisher so wenig Geld aus diesem
grundlagentopf abgerufen wurde oder
bewilligt wurde das sind ja nämlich
aktuell nur 12,5 Millionen und das
klingt ja jetzt im Vergleich zu den 100
Millionen doch recht wenig oder
das klingt erstmal wenig ich habe mir
die Anfrage der cdu/csu aus der sie
diese Zahlen hat aber noch mal angeguckt
und sie haben tatsächlich in diesen 12,5
Millionen einen Topf nicht
berücksichtigt und insgesamt sind es
nach den Zahlen die ich aus der Anfrage
heraus lese 22,5 Millionen Euro die
bisher schon da in die Forschung
geflossen sind
wir hatten als Ampelkoalition im letzten
Jahr auch ein Fachgespräch mit
verschiedenen Forscherinnen und
Forschern gemacht dazu woran sie
forschen und ähm welches Geld sie
tatsächlich auch für diese Forschung
noch konkret benötigen und da wurde sehr
deutlich dass es vor allem wichtig ist
dass dieses Geld jetzt auch über einen
längeren Zeitraum kontinuierlich zur
Verfügung gestellt wird das heißt wenn
jetzt erst ein bestimmter Teil abgerufen
wurde dann liegt das auch daran dass
viele der Forschungsvorhaben auf drei
vier oder fünf Jahre auch angelegt sind
und es ist uns natürlich wichtig dass
die auch in den kommenden Jahren dann
noch forschen und das Geld auch
kontinuierlich weiterhin abrufen können
Frau piepenhagen ihre Organisation ihre
Initiative die fordert ja auch deutlich
mehr Geld in diese Grundlagenforschung
können Sie diese Argumentation verstehen
nein gar nicht weil
das einfach in keinem Verhältnis steht
zu der Masse an Betroffenen die ja ein
wirtschaftlichen Schaden zur Folge hat
der gerade gestern ähm
veröffentlicht wurde aus einer
Untersuchung des Kieler Instituts für
Weltwirtschaft im letzten Jahr hatten
wir so viele Erkrankte wie seit der
Wiedervereinigung nicht mehr und das ist
ein Schaden allein für Deutschland der
42 Milliarden Euro gekostet haben sollte
und das wird uns wirtschaftlich in den
Ruin bringen wenn wir nicht mehr
Fördergelder dafür ausgeben die Menschen
wieder in die Arbeit zu bringen und zur
aktiven Pandemie als wir die Pandemie
eindämmen wollten und die Impfung
brauchten oder Medikamente in den
Krankenhäuser brauchten wurde eine
Milliarde an Geldern sofort und schnell
mit sonderregularien an Unternehmen
gebracht die auch nicht immer staatlich
waren also auch Unternehmer es wurden
ganz viel Gelder ganz schnell und
unkompliziert zur Verfügung gestellt und
jetzt in der postprovitphase haben die
Mediziner die forschen wollen und
tatsächlich konkrete
Arbeitshypothesen haben die den
Pathomechanismus verstanden haben und
ihre Dinge einsetzen wollen solche
bürokratischen Hürden und Regularien von
bis zu anderthalb Jahren auszuhalten
also dass wir uns fragen wie lange wir
eigentlich noch warten und wie viel
wirtschaftlichen Schaden wir noch
aushalten können in Deutschland in
Großbritannien ist das schon auf dem
Schirm die kanadische
Wirtschaftsministerin warnt von den
Folgen von Longboard und in Deutschland
Plätschern wir mit 12,5 Millionen ich
glaube damit können Sie gerade mal die
Stifte Spitzen um überhaupt die
bürokratischen die bürokratischen Hürden
zu bewältigen aber damit können Sie um
Gottes Willen nicht so vielen Menschen
denen wirklich schlecht geht ja forschen
und die Krankheitsmechanismen
unmöglich
Freiheit Mann was sagen sie dazu können
Sie das verstehen
ich kann das gut verstehen und auch mir
ist es tatsächlich wichtig dass jetzt
schnell sowohl Versorgung als auch gute
Grundlagenforschung passiert damit wir
diesen unterschiedlichsten
Krankheitsbildern die es in der Folge
von kovid gibt auch wirklich wirksam
begegnen können aber ich sag mal wir
können auch die Forschung nicht aus dem
Hut zaubern sondern es muss natürlich
auch forschende geben die sich dann auf
diese Gelder bewerben die gibt es auch
aber
sie sind momentan in einem Umfang von 55
Millionen in denen Geld da beantragt
sind soweit ich das weiß ähm und wir
sind natürlich gewillt diese Forschung
die da beantragt wird dann auch
bestmöglich zu ermöglichen ich möchte
aber auch davor waren
ja zu viel Hoffnung da rein zu
investieren das wirklich sehr schnell
jetzt Medikamente die wirksam sind und
Therapien sofort auf den Markt kommen
die jeden heilen können wir wissen
leider von vielen Krankheitsbildern dass
die Forschung an Medikamenten und an
Krankheiten sehr lange dauert und
deshalb ist es mir wirklich wichtig dass
wir hier auch kontinuierlich das beste
tun um diese Forschung zu ermöglichen
und dauerhaft auch zu ermöglichen
lassen sie uns nochmal auf den anderen
Teil Aspekt gucken es gibt ja auch
Menschen die
longkowitz also longkowitz Symptome nach
einer Impfung kriegen das ist ein
deutlich kleinerer Teil als die Menschen
die long Kurve nach einer Kurve der
Erkrankung kriegen aber es gibt eben
auch diese Post wachsen Syndrom und ähm
eine aus diesen Personenkreis die sich
engagiert ist ja die Schauspielerin
Felicia Binger mit der haben wir hier
vor ein paar Wochen schon gesprochen und
die sagt dazu folgendes
im Moment haben wir vor allem noch das
Problem dass die Versorgungsämter
oftmals die die impfgeschädigten gar
nicht anerkennen und auch dann bekommen
wir im besten Fall zwischen 200 und 800
Euro im Monat was einfach ein
schändliches Almosen ist für ein
zerstörtes Leben also da muss was
passieren und ich wünsche mir auch dass
auch die Hersteller uns unterstützen
natürlich denn es kann nicht sein dass
die Betroffenen jetzt überhaupt nicht
wissen wie sie ihre Rechnung bezahlen
sollen wie Sie Ihre Behandlung bezahlen
sollen
ja also auch da noch ein Problem mit der
Anerkennung dass diese Erkrankung dieses
Krankheitsbild überhaupt ernst genommen
wird Frau Heitmann was sagen sie dazu
das sehe ich ganz genauso ich glaube die
Post wagt Betroffenen haben leider das
gleiche Problem wie auch die longkowit
und mecfs erkrankten dass ihre
Erkrankung häufig nicht anerkannt und
nicht richtig
behandelt wird dann auch in der Folge
und ich setze deshalb auch die Hoffnung
dass die Versorgungsstrukturen die wir
aufbauen die hoffentlich besser werden
und auch die Therapien dann auch diesen
Menschen eine Hilfe bieten können und
ich glaube was ganz wichtig ist ist aber
auf jeden Fall immer auch noch in der
Ärzteschaft noch ein größeres
Bewusstsein und Wissen über dieses
Erkrankungsbild zu schaffen weil viele
der Betroffenen einfach immer wieder
merken dass sie auch bei ihrem regulären
Hausarzt gegen wen Rennen und nicht
ernst genommen werden und da gilt es
wirklich aufmerksam keit zu schaffen
deshalb bin ich Frau piepenhagen auch
sehr dankbar dass sie das auch mit der
Kundgebung heute noch mal ins
Bewusstsein gerückt hat wie sehr diese
Erkrankung auch in Deutschland viele
Menschen betrifft
vielleicht können wir abschließend noch
mal auf die ganz konkreten politischen
Forderungen gucken die es gerade gibt
Frau piepenhagen was muss jetzt ganz
konkret als nächstes passieren
also wir würden uns wünschen dass
erstmal eine massive Erhöhung der
forschungssumme aufgelegt wird damit man
überhaupt
adäquat forschen kann in der
Größenordnung wie wir sie her haben und
da können wir einfach nicht weit
springen mit dem Geld was zur Verfügung
gestellt wurde
ganz wichtig wäre erstmal die
statistische Erfassung der Fallzahlen
was ja in Deutschland auch nicht so
funktioniert und wie Frau Heitmann eben
sagte viele bekommen ja gar nicht die
Lung Profi Diagnose sondern
psychosomatische Diagnosen und werden so
gar nicht mitgezählt
ja
Zulassungsstudien natürlich klinische
Studien wir reden ja immer von wenig
evidenzbasiert aber wenn wir keine
ausreichenden Studien machen in großem
Umfang und zwar in der gesamten
Bundesrepublik und nicht nur an einem
Ort in Deutschland ja dann könnten wir
auch geeignete Therapiemöglichkeiten
finden und zwar ein bisschen schneller
als es möglich ist weil es gab ja auch
wie gesagt in der akuten Phase
Möglichkeiten der sonderregularien und
der schnelleren Prozesse oder
unbürokratische Dinge das scheint jetzt
in der postprofi Phase nicht so zu
brennen wie gesagt aber für die
Patienten die nicht mehr leben wollen
weil sie wirklich tagelang in
abgedunkelten Zimmern liegen müssen mit
Schallschutz Kopfhörern und Augenmaske
also für dieses unerträglich auch nur
noch zwei Wochen abzuwarten eigentlich
ja und da müsste unsere Regierung
eigentlich eine Task Force ins Leben
rufen um den Menschen zu helfen die die
da liegen und wirklich leiden den es
wirklich schlecht geht und die aus dem
Leben verschwinden sowohl aus dem
gesellschaftlichen Leben als auch aus
dem Arbeitsleben die verlieren ihre
Familien manche Eltern verlieren ihre
Kinder es gehört eine ganzheitliche
ärztliche Aufklärung dazu natürlich eine
bessere Vernetzung der Fachrichtung
untereinander den Ausbau der Long
Ambulanzen zu interdisziplinären
Behandlungszentren und die Vereinfachung
der bürokratischen Prozesse für die
London Profi Patienten die gar nicht in
der Lage sind diese wahnsinnigen
bürokratischen Hürden zu bewältigen um
Rente zu beantragen oder mit der
Unfallkasse oder mit der Krankenkasse zu
kommunizieren
ja ich denke es ist ganz deutlich
geworden dass es noch eine ganze Menge
zu tun gibt und deswegen denke ich
werden wir über dieses Thema auch noch
weiter im Gespräch bleiben aber ich
bedanke mich erstmal für dieses Gespräch
vielen Dank dass Sie beide bei uns waren
ich habe gerade mal so ein Blick in die
Kommentare geworfen und es scheint als
ob auch viele Betroffene gerade diesen
stream schauen hier schreibt z.B YouTube
User future Gohan danke schön dass ihr
berichtet ich leider schrecklich unter
longkurve seit 7 Monaten es kann jeden
treffen und auch
Youtuberin Heike sagt es müssen dringend
Forschungsgelder bereitgestellt werden
ich habe seit 25 Jahren mecfs das ist
dieses chronic fatic Syndrom das eben
auch im in der Folge von auftreten kann
Heike gesagt sie sind zwischen
bettlägerig pflegebedürftig und kaum
noch in der Lage zu kommunizieren wir
brauchen Medikamente kennt ihr jemanden
der betroffen ist schreibt uns das gerne
mal in die Kommentare ja wir haben
gerade gehört diese politische Dimension
dieses Problems ist unheimlich groß da
kann man ewig drüber sprechen lass uns
jetzt zum Schluss noch mal einen Blick
darauf werfen wie da eigentlich der
aktuelle Stand der Wissenschaft und der
Forschung ist und dazu hören wir noch
mal rein was die Postbank Betroffene
Dinge sagt
ich hoffe natürlich dass wir bald
Behandlungsmethoden konkret haben dass
wir konkret Medikamente haben die helfen
können und dafür muss natürlich erstmal
geforscht werden und auch geguckt werden
wem hilft zum Beispiel die
immunabsorption bei vielen ist es ein
Erfolg bei vielen ist es aber auch kein
Erfolg also man muss da einfach genau
hinschauen wem hilft was etwas und warum
und trotzdem haben wir auch jetzt ja
noch nicht die Behandlung wo man sagt
das hilft auf jeden Fall also wir sind
da ja noch weit entfernt aber ich hoffe
natürlich dass es da hoffentlich bald
Durchbruch geben wird
ja und darüber was hilft und was nicht
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit
Professor Carmen scheibenbogen sie ist
langkurve Expertin an der Charité schön
dass Sie bei uns sind ja guten Abend
wie bewerten sie denn diese
vorangegangene Diskussion wir haben ja
gehört der der Druck bei den Betroffenen
das Leid ist ziemlich hoch und die
Politik reagiert gerade was auch diese
Förderung angeht er schleppend
ja also ich kann dem was wir gerade
gehört haben nur zustimmen wir haben
eine große versorgungsnot wir haben sehr
viele Betroffene wir haben ganz gute
Zahlen nicht aus Deutschland aber zum
Beispiel aus England wir können also
wirklich davon ausgehen dass wir
mindestens eine Millionen Betroffene
haben jetzt in Deutschland wenn nicht
sogar noch höhere Zahlen und viele von
denen sind auch
schwer krank viele sind berufsunfähig
wir sehen zum Beispiel aus England auch
dass wir infolge der Pandemie zusätzlich
eine halbe Million Menschen haben die
nicht mehr arbeitsfähig sind und wir
haben eine große versorgungsnot viele
dieser Menschen haben keine adäquate
ärztliche Betreuung und das hat auch
damit zu tun dass man diese
postinfektionen Erkrankung bis heute
nicht gut verstanden hat und viele Ärzte
sich auch mit diesen Erkrankungen fast
nicht auskennen
jetzt wurde ja im Laufe dieser
Diskussion immer mal wieder davon
gesprochen dass es jetzt vor allem auf
Medikamente ankommt und es gibt ja schon
ein Medikament was irgendwie ganz
vielversprechend ist das heißt BC 007
wie muss man sich das denn vorstellen
jetzt gibt es irgendwie ein Medikament
was hilft aber das ist noch nicht auf
dem Markt oder
ja also da muss man dazu sagen wir
wissen nicht ob das wirklich hilft das
gab lediglich
Heilversuche bei drei oder vier
Patienten und wir müssen Medikamente in
klinischen Studien sauber prüfen um zu
sehen wirken diese Medikamente bei wem
wirken diese Medikamente und da haben
wir auch das Problem dass das ja relativ
komplexe Erkrankungen sind also wir
haben ja schon gehört mecfs das
chronische Partizip Syndrom ist ein Teil
dieser postcode Erkrankung aber wir
haben andere Krankheitsbilder wir haben
Menschen die haben schwere
Kreislaufprobleme wir haben Menschen die
haben schwere Neuro kognitive Symptome
und wir wissen auch dass hinter diesen
Krankheitsbildern unterschiedliche
Mechanismen stecken wir wissen also das
zum einen dass Immunsystem oft
überreagierte wissen aber auch das
Gefäßentzündung eine Rolle spielen wir
wissen dass bei manchen im virusreste
noch nachweisbar sind und wir gehen also
auch davon dass wir nicht mit einem
Medikament alle behandeln können das
können wir ja auch bei anderen
Erkrankungen nicht und hier ist es umso
herausfordernden das heißt wir müssen
ganz viele Medikamente in klinischen
Studien prüfen und da sagen wir sollten
auch schon zugelassene Medikamente
setzen das bc-007 ist ja ein Medikament
das ist noch früh in der klinischen
Entwicklung das gibt es ja noch gar
nicht für die Behandlung von Erkrankung
aber all diese Mechanismen die ich
gerade genannt habe da haben wir
natürlich schon Medikamente aus anderen
Erkrankungen die zugelassen sind und
diese Medikamente die ähm könnte man
auch sehr viel schneller in die Klinik
bringen das heißt direkt für die
Anwendung der Patienten und da haben wir
ähm vor einem Jahr auch ähm diese
nationale klinische Studiengruppe an der
Charité gegründet in der wir
Forschung mit Therapie Studien
kombinieren das heißt wir ähm
setzen bereits jetzt erste Medikamente
ein wir beginnen also mit den ersten
Studien oder haben schon begonnen und
wir machen aber gleichzeitig eine
umfangreiche biomarkerforschung und auch
diagnostische Analysen bei diesem
Patienten um zum einen mehr über die
Erkrankung zu lernen aber auch dann
wirklich sagen zu können dieses
Medikament hilft jetzt nehmen und wir
würden dann in Folge auch versuchen
diese Medikamente relativ schnell zur
Zulassung zu bringen
wer ist denn jetzt an dieser Stelle von
der sie gerade sprechen wer ist denn da
jetzt gefragt damit es zu dazu kommt das
zugelassene Medikamente genutzt werden
damit es dazu kommt dass mehr
Medikamente getestet werden wir sprechen
ja ganz viel über politische finanzielle
Förderung aber wie muss man das
verstehen wenn da jetzt mehr Geld rein
fließen sollte führt das automatisch
auch zu mehr Lösungen also wer ist
gerade gefragt ja also wir brauchen zum
einen Geld das Geld muss entweder aus
der öffentlichen Förderung kommen oder
aber es muss auch von der
pharmazeutischen Industrie kommen da
sage ich auch schon lange die müssen
einfach auch mit in die Verantwortung
genommen werden und ich habe
vorgeschlagen dass man einen runden
Tisch macht dass man alle einlädt die
potenzielle Medikamente haben denn die
könnten auch mit uns zusammen solche
Medikamente entwickeln das ist ja
heutzutage extrem aufwendig klinische
Studien zu machen wir haben hohe
regulatorische Hürden der Datenschutz
ist sehr groß und wir könnten wirklich
diese professionelle Unterstützung aus
der pharmazeutischen Industrie auch
brauchen die auch relativ unkompliziert
zugelassenen Medikamente zur Verfügung
stellen könnten aber natürlich gibt es
auch viele an den Universitäten die
klinische Studien machen können und
dafür bedarf es aber dann finanzieller
Förderung des BMBF kann Geld für
Forschung und für
Medikamentenentwicklung zur Verfügung
stellen und noch mal kurz zur
Versorgungsforschung und Demon ein
Konzept das Lauterbach vorgestellt hat
ich halte auch das für extrem wichtig
denn es ist ja nicht so dass man gar
nichts machen kann viele Menschen sind
ja auch sehr krank haben schlimme
Schmerzen haben schwere Schlafstörungen
haben Kreislaufprobleme da können wir
natürlich heute zumindest schon lindern
mit Medikamenten aber da ist leider das
wissen oft bei den Ärzten gar nicht da
was jetzt der richtige Ansatz ist also
wir könnten heute schon zum zumindest
helfen und dazu braucht es auch bessere
Versorgungsstrukturen wir haben zwar
Ambulanzen an vielen Stellen in
Deutschland aber die sind oft ganz
einseitig ausgerichtet und da fehlt oft
auch die Erfahrung gerade wie man solche
Krankheitsbilder wie im ecfs oder Pots
behandelt
lassen sie uns nochmal auf diesen Aspekt
der pharmazeutischen Industrie gucken da
gibt es nämlich auch eine Frage aus der
Community und zwar fragt Axel Godzilla
auf Youtube der Vergleich das Aufwand
ist der bei der Impfstoffentwicklung
betrieben wurde mit dem der jetzt bei
der Erforschung der Ursache für long Kur
wird und me CFS geworden wird ist
deprimierend wie kann man diesen
Unterschied der da in der öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung entsteht erklären
ich kann es auch nicht gut erklären es
ist ja für uns alle auch ein großes
Problem also einmal die die große Not
dieser ganzen Kranken und ihrer
Angehörigen aber wir haben es ja auch
schon gehört das ist ja auch ein
wirtschaftliches Problem es kostet ja
auch viel Geld das so viele Menschen
krank sind und aus dem Berufsleben
fallen und wir brauchen die ja dringend
sind ja überwiegend junge Leute und am
Ende ist das Geld was wir investieren
wenn wir diese Menschen behandeln können
aus ihrer Erkrankung rausholen ist ja
sehr gut angelegt
wir haben hier aus der Community noch
eine Fachfrage an sie die stellen sich
bestimmt gerade viele User da draußen
die Frage und zwar frag Richard auf
Youtube wie wird denn eigentlich
festgestellt dass es sich um longkow
wird und nicht um Postbank handelt
nun zum einen ist die Krankengeschichte
erstmal ganz wichtig das enge zeitliche
Zusammenhang zwischen der Infektion und
der Erkrankung wir haben natürlich auch
Marker das heißt wir haben die
Möglichkeit eine Stadt gehabt der
Infektion auch zu einem späteren
Zeitpunkt noch über Antikörper zu messen
aber es gibt jetzt noch nicht den einen
Marker wo sie nur über den Bluttest
sagen können derjenige hat jetzt
longkow wird oder der hat postwag wobei
es so ist das diese Erkrankung sicher
sehr stark ähneln also wir haben aber
auch Menschen die nach einer Impfung das
Vollbild von im ecfs entwickeln oder
Putz entwickeln und wir wissen noch
nicht so viel über die
Krankheitsmechanismen was da passiert
aber wir gehen davon aus dass das
möglicherweise auch die gleichen
Mechanismen sind dass wir auch da ist zu
tun haben mit
Auto Antikörper die ähm gegen das
bikeprotein gerichtet sind und dann auch
Kreuz reagieren können und da sind
einige Beispiele schon das gerade auch
ähm solche Strukturen im an die das
Virus andockt die ähm für die
Kreislaufregulation verantwortlich sind
das dagegen auch Antikörper gebildet
werden und wir wissen auch dass die
Aktivierung von anderen
dass das wahrscheinlich auch eine Rolle
mitspielt weil man
sie haben auch gerade noch mal gesagt
ist ja auch noch mal ein guter Gegenpool
zu der Diskussion gerade dass sie diese
100 Millionen in die
Versorgungsforschung extrem wichtig
finden und dazu passend hat uns jemand
auf Facebook geschrieben und zwar Jörg
Pauls der sagt meine Frau ist seit
letztem Jahr im Mai an long koved
erkrankt und seitdem krankgeschrieben
man weiß viel zu wenig darüber hoffe
wenn sie jetzt bald zur Reha kommt dass
ihr dort geholfen wird also auch jemand
der auf die Versorgungssicherheit sitzt
und für denen das extrem wichtig ist ähm
jetzt haben wir hier noch eine sehr
spezifische Frage an Sie aber ich stelle
Ihnen da einfach mal ich glaube da ist
jemand involviert der auf jeden Fall
sehr im Thema ist und zwar fragt Cloud
guy auf YouTube in den Diskursen zu Post
viralen Schäden spielen ja auch die
sogenannten GPCR Antikörper eine Rolle
kann man hier nicht ansetzen
ja das ist ein Forschungsthema an dem
wir in der Tat schon eine lange arbeiten
denn wir wissen dass das Krankheitsbild
mecfs auch zu einer schweren Störung
führt der unbewussten Körpersteuerung
und da spielt die Stressreaktion das
Adrenalin wichtige Rolle und
diese Stressreaktion wird gesteuert über
die sogenannten g-proding gekoppelten
Rezepte Antikörper und da wissen wir
dass die Steuerung bei mecfs gestört ist
und wir haben jetzt das genauso auch
gesehen bei postkowith Patienten die an
im ecfs erkrankt sind und
wir gehen davon aus dass
möglicherweise diese Menschen auch so
behandelt werden können wie wir es auch
bei anderen Autoimmunerkrankungen machen
wir haben an der Charité schon vor
mehreren Jahren ein kleines Studien
gemacht zu immunabraktion da waschen wir
also einmal alle Antikörper raus und
haben gesehen dass das vielen Patienten
auch sehr schnell helfen kann
und wir machen jetzt aktuell wieder eine
erste Studie mit immunabsorptionen bei
denen die nach kovid an dem ecfs
erkrankt sind und sehen das genauso auch
dass das hilft also das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Ansatz wobei das soll man
relativ komplexes Thema ist mit diesen
Antikörpern denn das ist nicht ein
Antikörper der nur bei Krankheiten
auftaucht dann sind Antikörper die wir
alle haben und mit denen wir auch im
gesunden Zustand und unsere
Stressantwort steuern und deswegen im
Winter auch noch viele Fragen ungeklärt
und auch da Bedarf natürlich dringend
mehr Unterstützung an Forschung und
vielleicht noch ganz kurzer Kommentar es
gibt natürlich ganz viele
Wissenschaftler in Deutschland die ähm
jetzt aus dem Stand in der Lage werden
an diesen Krankheitsbildern zu forschen
wenn man mal schaut 2021 gab es ja fünf
Millionen und die ausgeschrieben wurden
von BMWF das sind über 80 Anträge
eingegangen von denen ich glaube gerade
mal im 10 gefördert wurden und
die haben ja viele Erkrankungen und
diese Autoimmunerkrankung entzündliche
Erkrankung Gefäßerkrankungen an denen
Wissenschaftler in Deutschland schon
heute im großen Umfang forschen und wir
könnten also dieses dieses Potenzial
natürlich nutzen um ganz schnell auch an
mehr über
aus Kohle zu lernen und auch ganz
schnell Therapie studieren zu starten
aber nicht wiederhole mich wir brauchen
dafür Förderung
ja und so wie Sie sehen das auch die
meisten User hier ist schreibt auf
Youtube Axel guzzler noch mal die Sache
ist ganz einfach Deutschland muss
deutlich mehr Geld in die Forschung
investieren beim
Bundesforschungsministerium scheint der
Ernst der Lage noch nicht erkannt worden
zu sein und Christine Möcker hat uns per
Mail geschrieben mit kleinen
Kleckerbeträgen die bisher von Frau
stark Watzinger bewilligt wurden lässt
sich rein gar nichts bewegen wie können
wir das denn jetzt zum Schluss noch mal
zusammenfassen sie sagen auch ihre
politische Forderung ist es mehr
Forschung aber auch die Pharmaindustrie
muss mitziehen oder genau und das Beste
wäre wir würden die Pharmaindustrie
fragen was sie vielleicht benötigt dass
wir das und sonst zusammen tun für die
ist möglicherweise
dass Risiko auch ähm momentan noch zu
hoch das möglicherweise da
vielleicht auch ähm Mechanismen doch
noch und so reichen verstanden ich kann
es nicht genau sagen aber dann müssten
wir eben vielleicht sagen dann tun wir
uns zusammen dann fördern wir zumindest
ein Teil der klinischen Studien und ihr
tut euren Teil dazu
Frau Scheiben vielen Dank dass Sie bei
uns waren und dass sie meine Fragen und
die aus der Community beantwortet haben
danke schön
ja ihr seht für ganz viele Menschen ist
diese Pandemie noch lange nicht vorbei
lonkovic ist ein Thema was ich würde mal
sagen von der Regierung auf jeden Fall
erkannt ist also man kann nicht sagen
dass die Regierung longkurve total
ignoriert aber wir haben es gerade
gehört es scheint oft auch noch an der
Vernetzung zu ja zu fehlen zwischen der
Pharmaindustrie zwischen der Regierung
und aber auch zwischen dem Betroffenen
ich denke wir bleiben da weiterhin dran
wie vielleicht sprechen wir noch mal
über dieses Thema ich freue mich wenn
ihr wieder einschaltet danke für eure
Kommentare und bis bald